grab a plate of potatoes and get ready
to head back to PanAm here's a breakdown
of the 10th Hunger Games Snow's
short-lived Excursion to the districts
and where he and Lucy gray landed after
the games The Ballad of song birds and
snakes takes audiences through the 10th
Hunger Games and Cy Elena Snow's role as
a mentor to Lucy grey be the female
tribute from District 12 at the
beginning the snow family is in ruin an
able to pay rent and struggling to
maintain their place in capital Society
the plinth prize a scholarship to the
university should change their life but
the Academy students find out that they
need to complete one last project to
prove themselves before the Winner's
announcement each student in the
graduating class has assigned a tribute
to Mentor their job is to make a
spectacle of them to help encourage
citizens to watch the annual games snow
takes this job particularly seriously
going against the grain and breaking the
rules of the project to guide Lucy gray
to Victory however his choices catch up
with him when the dean of the Academy
Casa High bottom discovers Snow's
cheating and banishes him to a 20year
sentence as a peacekeeper snow pays off
a member of the capital military to be
assigned to District 12 wanting to know
if Lucy gray makes it home while there
snow continues to make selfish decisions
to ensure his survival after snow kills
a M's daughter and Witnesses the death
of her boyfriend alongside s Janus and
Lucy gray he and the winner of the 10th
Hunger Games decide to run away from
panm and go up north while on their
Journey the dynamic between the two
changes Lucy gray realizes there noow
lied to her and tries to leave snow puts
together what she's doing and follows
her resulting in a snake bite from a
trap she set when he thinks he sees her
he uses a gun to shoot in her Direction
she falls but when he checks on her
she's gone snow heads back to District
12 ready to go to officer training in
District 2 however he's instead sent to
the capital for an apprenticeship under
Dr G the head game maker of the 10th
games because of the information he sent
her about s Janus and the rebels but
snow can't have someone ruining this
chapter in his life so he also
eliminates who he perceives as his final
enemy High bottom when audiences meet
snow he is self assured and confident
that he is the winner of the plinth
prize however the new project causes him
to question the purpose of the games and
the inherent nature of mankind he finds
himself struggling with his motivations
to cheat telling himself it's for Lucy
gray not for himself after entering the
arena to save sanus snow kills one of
the tributes he realizes how quickly
someone's goals can change to protect
themselves but it's still shocked that
he took someone's life at this moment no
understands that humans will do anything
in the name of self-preservation and he
needs to act first moving forward
everything is about winning when he
moves to District 12 as part of his
military service this notion only
intensifies as he begins to hurt others
for his own gain he kills someone who
could report s janus's actions not to
protect sanus but to protect himself he
then throws sanus under the bust to keep
his name clear but Lucy gray turns the
tables on him seemingly bested at his
own game snow returns to District 12 and
continues on to the capital in poisoning
high botom he cements his new life View
and how he will handle business moving
forward it's a dark path but snow
doesn't hesitate the movie opens with
snow losing his trust in the academy he
works hard to earn the plinth prize and
be able to support his family only to
find out at the last minute there's
another obstacle to overcome before he
can claim the award as his own then he
can't trust his new obstacle because
High bottom says he will do anything to
prevent snow from winning the
scholarship he also learns that despite
what she says he can't trust Lucy Gray
even though he gives up everything for
her if you can trust anyone in this
world you can trust me in his eyes Lucy
gray betrays him she leaves him sets up
a trap for him and decides to continue
on without him she's the only person he
can trust in the district and when she
leaves him his grandmother's ideas about
the nature of District people resonate
with snow to him the only person who
will ever look out for him is himself
it's an important lesson to learn and
helps inform audiences about the choices
snow makes moving forward as audiences
Watch Snow make all these tough
decisions it becomes clear that he's
slowly but surely turning to the dark
side snow rationalizes his actions
during the games because he's trying to
help someone else he argues that winning
doesn't just benefit him since it also
ensures his cousin and grandmother are
taken care of however his later actions
in district 12 are purely for personal
gain and show how he's letting go of the
whole notion of being a good person he
doesn't hesitate to turn sanus in or to
turn his gun towards Lucy gray when they
aren't serving a purpose in his life
anymore he is the one who survives in
the end which only reinforces him that
he made the right choices in these
situations the ballot of song birds and
snakes shows every side of humanity from
the good to the evil but the Kat
unexpectedly displays the most humanity
is Casa High bottom in the final moments
of the movie we learned that high bottom
along with snow father is responsible
for the Hunger Games they drunkenly came
up with the idea together and Snow's
father submitted it to drg gal behind
High Bottom's back years later H botam
feels guilty that his idea caused the
death of so many children he admits to
snow that that he tried to cancel the
games and now fears that Snow's actions
will ensure the games live on forcing H
botom to continue to have blood on his
hands this information combined with the
knowledge that he gives Lucy gy money
before she goes back to District 12
reinforces the idea that despite what
he's been through hi Bottom never lost
his Humanity in contrast snow definitely
loses his Humanity following the same
path as Dr gal he comes around to
believing that all humans are inherently
evil and the game simply remind the
citizens of panm of that snow takes on
his father role becoming the evil
counterparts to high Bottom's good you
can either cross that land into
evil or not at this point we have to
speculate a little bit Lucy gray
seemingly got up and walked away after
falling in the forest but what
ultimately happened to her is still a
mystery there are numerous theories
trying to account for her life and death
many of which first materialized with
the release of the book some of them
still apply to her ambiguous sending in
the film one of the leading theories is
that Lucy gray survives eventually
returning to District 12 where she had
children and became Katniss evine's
grandmother this Theory hinges on the
passing down of the Hanging Tree song
the similarities in their personalities
until they both have a tendency to Vex
snow some even argue that President Snow
suspects this and that's why he feels so
threatened by katness in the time of the
main Hunger Games franchise another
theory is that Lucy gray did make it up
north starting a new life away from panm
and Breaking Free from the rule of the
capital variations of the theory say she
even made it to District 13 becoming a
part of the underground society that
lives there after the first Rebellion
maybe she continued to watch Snow from
afar seeing how the man she thought she
knew turned away from the light forever
in the end though her fate is still a
mystery and Mysteries have a way of
driving people mad the ending of The
Ballad of song birds and snakes has many
moving Parts but it was always a
foregone conclusion that snow would turn
into a bad guy we all know he eventually
grows up into this fellow The Narrative
challenge of song birds and snakes was
convincing the audience to root for snow
all the way up to the end then when he
fully embraced his villain the moment
would feel all the more real as producer
Nina Jacobson told scream Rand you have
to have this like desire to somehow want
to see him go make a different decision
even though you know he won't and yet
ultimately you have to get to a place
where it feels really satisfying when he
finally lets go of the impulse to do
good and let himself be the villain we
know he will ultimately become director
Francis Lawrence agreed telling scream
rant so when he does go dark which I
think people find very satisfying it
feels aable and honest and truthful
Jacobson and Lawrence agreed that there
was never a question as to whether snow
would go down a dark path it was just a
question of what he would encounter
along the way the ballad of song birds
and snakes doesn't have a mid credits or
post-credits scene leaving audiences
with nothing to chew on as they
speculate what a sequel could look like
while there isn't yet another book
between the ballad of song birds and
snakes and The Hunger Games the creative
team behind the movies has ideas about
where a sequel could go and who it would
focus on Nina Jacobson told people I
would would love to see Snow's rise to
power because he's just a great
character but it's tigis and
understanding how this girl who loves
him so and cares for him and becomes a
woman that we saw in McKing Jay that I'm
really fascinated by until snow decided
I wasn't pretty enough anymore that idea
has a backing of actress Hunter schaer
who portrayed Tigress in The Ballad of
song birds and snakes she told
Entertainment Weekly I want to know what
happens even if I wasn't playing her I
want to know how we get there Lawrence
and Jacobson do know that author suzan
has a final say but they are always open
to hearing her ideas as Lawrence told ew
if suzan has another thematic idea that
she feels fits into the world of panm
I'd be really interested in looking at
it and being a part of it of course
there are other stories fans of the
series would love to see two that come
up often are hey Mitch's Hunger Games
which are the 50th Hunger Games and
Phenix games which he won at 14 years
old as the youngest Victor up to that
point while additional films of this
nature would satisfy the fan base's want
for more content once again it's up to
Collins to decide if we ever get to see
them as Francis Lawrence told ew Suzanne
always writes from a thematic Foundation
that's what makes them feel rich and not
superficial and I think it's why they've
stood the test of time honestly that
means the future of the film franchise
rests in the hands of the author the
creative team is willing and ready to
bring more stories to life but only if
Collins is the one writing them in a
world where so many sequels are made
based on the money they could bring in
that's a refreshing perspective we can
rest assured that if we ever do revisit
panm on the SC it will be for a story
wor
seeing